[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily r
kelly's ex-girlfriend takes the stand
against him the r b singer accused of
forcing the woman and aaliyah to have
abortions and case closed the officer
who shot ashley babbitt during the
capital riot is officially cleared of
any wrongdoing you have to ask did the
officer act with reasonable force given
what was presented to him plus robert
durst's explanation for everything i'm
not a normal person
the real estate heir under
cross-examination accused in the murder
of his best friend and disappearance of
his first wife law and crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin we begin with r kelly's trial and
the explosive testimony about alleged
lies rapes and forced abortions
jane doe five was back on the stand for
the second day of testimony her
testimony dove deeper into her
allegations of alleged rape transporting
a minor and abortions jane doe five who
met r kelly when she was 17 years old in
2015 lived with him until 2019 allegedly
being flown all over the country for him
she testified that there were rules to
be followed like wearing baggy clothes
and when some rules were broken like
speaking to his other girlfriends about
the relationship she was punished by
being forced to have sex with a man
named nephew without her consent she
also testified that r kelly kosher into
lies to her family on the phone in fake
letters and even when being interviewed
by cbs's gail king prior to her moving
out in october of 2019. jane doe 5 told
the jury about an ask me anything
conversation where r kelly allegedly
told her and others that alia was
pregnant and needed a certificate to
possibly get an abortion and other than
her parents the only other person that
could go with her was her spouse all
this came out in direct
cross-examination will soon follow
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney bernardo violona and terry
austin bernard jane doe 5 gave us a
greater detail of r kelly's alleged
abuse is there anything the defense can
do against his powerful testimony
so brian there's a lot that the defense
can do but we have to focus on jane doe
number five she is so important to this
case she's important because out of the
racketeering acts which they are 11
she's named in four of them and aside
from that also as the accounts of the
man act she is also the primary victim
in four of those counts which took place
here in new york i think the way for the
defense to attack this not that i'm
condoning any of this is number one go
for credibility argue it was this
consensual this behavior or did it just
not happen or i think which is their
strongest argument is to argue that this
case does not fall under the rico statue
of racketeering organizations corrupt
organizations act yeah of course those
are all different aspects but let's
touch on the one part that bernardo
touched on uh terry and that's
credibility because you know jaronda
pace aaliyah and now jane doe five the
allegations all seem to be consistent
when talking about alleged abuse
credibility being everything for these
types of cases what did you make of jane
doe fives uh direct
i thought she was extremely credible and
her testimony is exactly consistent with
jaronda pace she was saying some of the
exact same things she said that he was
violent he was controlling he checked
her phone to see what she was actually
saying to her friends she had to get
permission she said to go to the
restroom and sometimes she even had to
urinate in a cup so i think that you
know she was extremely credible she
cried on the stand and the fact that she
was so young when this occurred i think
the jury is going to take her testimony
and couple it with what they've heard so
far and i think at the end of the day
it's going to be very credible yeah and
jane donald number five don't forget
lived with r kelly for i think about
four years again from 2015 to 2019 and a
lot of these allegations seem to span
that time and go into really details you
brought it up terry about the urinating
but also i think i heard something about
eating species or or something along
those lines um the more grotestine these
allegations get terry is gonna be harder
for them to say this was consensual but
just went too far
oh absolutely i think it's definitely
going to be difficult to defend those
types of actions yeah especially when i
think you juxtapose the age and and the
lack of consent i understand the parents
are involved to some degree but it's
going to be a tough uh road for the
defense to travel thank you both
turning now to more top legal news and
an update on the disappearance of
colorado mom suzanne morphy
or susan morphy sorry a judge will
decide if there's probable cause for her
husband to stand trial for her murder
barry morpheus accused of killing his
wife suzanne on mother's day 2020. an
fbi agent testified that during an
interview ten months later more of you
asked what about immunity can you give
me immunity if i just sit and open my
life up to you prosecutors say the
morpheus marriage was on the rocks and
suzanne was having an affair with
another man barry morphe reportedly kept
a tranquilizer gun and dates in their
home agents say that gun was fired on
the last day suzanne was seen alive
morpho denies it was and an unused
22-caliber round was found next to the
couple's bed
switching gears to california where a
preliminary hearing is underway for the
accused killers of college student
kristin smart an fbi agent says he
planted a jailhouse informant to try to
get paul flores to confess flores was
the last person to see smart at cal poly
in 1996. for years investigators
suspected flores but unable to find her
body he was not charged until this past
april now investigators believe flores
killed smart in her dorm room his father
ruben flores is accused of helping him
cover up the crime flores never
confessed and maintains his innocence
rapper tory lanes was ordered to pay out
for violating a restraining order
against fellow rapper megan v stallion a
judge increased tory lanez's bail to 250
000 on monday tory lanez is accused of
making a surprise visit at a music
festival just after megan the stallion
left the stage
the judge warned tory lanez that he
faces more than 22 years in prison for
allegations of shooting megan visalian
in the foot
lanes apologized and posted his
increased bail
still ahead on law and crime daily will
prosecutors catch robert durst in yet
another lie but first the capitol rights
a decision for the officer accused of
shooting and killing ashley babbitt
inside the investigation after the break
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back a u.s capitol police
officer will not be disciplined after he
shot and killed a woman during the u.s
capitol riots law and crime's angela
levy is here with more on this now
closed case
yeah brian there was an outcry you'll
recall from some people after that
capitol police officer shot and killed
ashley babbitt she was not armed but now
capitol police say that officer has been
officially cleared
on january 6 surveillance video captured
a throng of people including air force
veteran ashley babbitt forcing their way
into the capitol a police officer fired
killing babbitt capital police now say
that officer will not be disciplined
former federal prosecutor jean rossi on
the finding
it suggests to me
that the level of evidence that was
gathered by the department of justice
and the u.s attorney's office must have
been pretty significant because they
administrative folks in the department
of um office of professional
responsibility
they concluded that there wasn't even
enough for the lower burden to find
administrative problems with this
officer in a press release capitol
police wrote the actions of the officer
in this case potentially saved members
and staff from serious injury and
possible death from a large crowd of
rioters who forced their way into the
u.s capitol it went on to say the
officer's actions were consistent with
the officer's training and uscp policies
and procedures the killing of ashley
babbitt drew a strong reaction from some
who were sympathetic to those who
stormed the building but rossi says the
question that has to be answered was
whether the officer's use of force was
reasonable and whether he feared for his
life and the lives of others
the death
of ashley babbitt is a tragedy under any
circumstances
it's a tragedy her life was taken sadly
there was a mob in front of that door
that led to the area of the chamber of
the house of representatives
the door and the glass were being broken
and smashed
and this is
a tragic a result
of that action by the mob
an attorney for ashley babbitt's family
released a statement disagreeing of
course with the findings of u.s capitol
police and that attorney called the
finding or the shooting rather
unjustified
in april federal prosecutors determined
that the officer who shot ashley babbitt
would not face criminal charges brian
thanks angenet let's bring back criminal
defense attorney bernardo violona and
terry austin to discuss terry i can
understand why there would not be any
legal charges or discipline but could
this have been a situation where
non-deadly force should have been used
you know what brian i agree 100 percent
with what gene rossi just said it's a
tragic situation and whenever you can
you should use force that doesn't result
in the death of another person but here
we have to look at what was in this
officer's mind and also in the minds of
the other officers who were involved if
in fact they thought their lives were in
danger and we know for a fact that they
did then we can't say that this was
either illegal or that it violated the
policy of the police and we know that
brian sicknick was one of the
individuals who was killed in this
instance so i think that the conclusion
was a reasonable conclusion obviously it
was a tragic result but the fact that we
did have a police officer who died we
had people who were storming and
breaking windows i think it was the
right result at the end of the day now
bernardo you know decisions create
precedence do you think not prosecuting
this officer and not disciplining him is
the right decision so i definitely think
this was the right decision you got to
think that when it talks about bringing
charges to any individual including this
officer that the prosecutor's office the
department of justice has to look at all
the facts because in the end it's not
about getting a conviction but more of
seeking justice and based on their
evaluation of all the evidence they were
led to believe that they could not prove
that this officer acted with any kind of
malice or with intent to cause the death
of this individual but rather that his
actions were justified and that a jury
will find as such every case is
different you look at the facts and
that's what's going to happen to any
other cases that come up in the future
however this will be a point of
reference but we know that january 6
wasn't your ordinary day and we don't
predict that will be happening again
let's hope not and jeanette what do you
know about the officer who fired at
ashley babbitt
you know brian we really don't know a
whole lot the u.s capitol police are not
releasing that officer's name in that
press release that they put out they
said that the officer and the officer's
family had received many threats so
obviously there is a concern for his
safety and the safety of his family also
ashley babbitt's family really doesn't
know much either they are actually suing
to get more information about that
officer all right we'll see how that
civil suit continues but i guess his
lame is probably going to be kept under
hush for quite some time thank you all
coming up on law and crime daily to dig
or not to dig the note robert durst
admits to writing that police say
explains how his wife vanished decades
ago does his explanation make sense you
decide next
[Music]
welcome back we look to california where
robert durst is finally has an
explanation for the infamous dig note
found in his home shortly after his wife
disappeared
town dump bridge dig boat other and
shovel this list of peculiar items was
found in robert durst's trash can
shortly after his wife kathy went
missing in 1982 while durst is currently
on trial for the murder of his best
friend susan berman durst is also
accused of murdering his first wife
but he's never been charged with kathy's
murder because her body has not been
found the notorious digno caused a lot
of speculation over the years since
these items could be linked to disposing
of a body now we finally get an
explanation
this looks like
a list
of how you would get rid of a body
that's what it looks like to you
it does not look like that to me at all
they would see it says town dump
which was my reference
that i was going to tell the high school
kids
who took care of the house
to take our rotting sailboat
to the town dump
d-i-g
is for digital
i had bought
the ms
hyphen-goss
microsoft
controls
book
with the computer
which i was planning
to work on
shovel
with the snow shovels
and i had asked the high school kids
who were gonna get rid of the sailboat
at the dump
to buy two snow shovels
back to break down another day of durst
cross examination is criminal defense
attorney bernardo violona and terry and
co-host terry austin terry this seems
like a bizarre note however you read it
but is it a stretch for the prosecution
to say this is proof of kathy's
disappearance
i think lewin has a great inference here
this list definitely looks like it's one
of the things that he's putting together
to try to figure out how to make his
wife's body disappear i mean it all
makes sense shovel getting rid of this
boat that makes no sense to me but it's
just one of many inferences one of the
other inferences that louie is asking
the jury to do is to think about when he
went to cal doors shortly after his
wife's death the fact that perhaps like
he did with morris black he is shopping
for items to help him dispose of the
body and don't forget about that blue
light he has said that that might have
been when he was actually dismembering
the body the neighbor saw the light on
for two days straight so i think these
are good inferences and i think because
we have had so many lies from durst that
for a fact the jury is going to think
about these inferences now bernard durst
dug deep into his bag of excuses for
this one but did it sound credible to
you
not at all brian he dug so deep actually
he was staring if you notice that when
he was going through that list he did
not blink once look the jury i think
with this one since it's so apparent so
apparent that those items are items that
can be used in order to get rid of the
body and we already know that thirst has
experience with getting rid of a body
because guess what he dismembered robert
black and morris black and he had to
admit to it so we all know that already
and the timing of when this list came
out after she disappears yeah okay durst
yeah i i'm i'm smirking because my mom
definitely knows that blank stare of
trying to find an excuse for what you
did and why
i think that's a common thing that many
people do when they're trying to lie or
find something i i don't know what the
jury is going to believe but that dig
note was beyond me uh of course we'll
continue to follow the robert durst
trial law and crimes got you covered for
gal to gavel coverage when we come back
robert durst's story still doesn't add
up his claim that the killer was still
in the house when he discovered susan
berman dead more on how his claims
contradicts prior testimony
[Music]
welcome back we're continuing our
coverage of robert durst trial and his
shocking claims on the stand
now saying he thinks susan berman's
killer was in her house when he
discovered her body
robert durst is on trial for the murder
of his best friend susan berman durst
discovered berman was shot in the head
in her beverly hills home in december
2000. duress claims he fled the scene
fearing he would get framed for the
murder instead of calling the cops durst
sent the infamous cadaver note to lead
the police to discover berman's body
earlier under direct examination durst
claimed that susan's body was cold when
he found it now durr says he thinks the
killer was still in the house when he
arrived on cross prosecutor john lewin
noticed that those two stories don't
exactly add up
i believe the killer was either still in
the house
or in the yard when i arrived
mr durst haven't you testified that
susan's body was cold
i did not testify
that susan's body was cold
the breath fell her face felt cold
her br she's dead
what do you mean her breath felt
was she breathing on you when you got
there no she was not breathing so how
can her breath be cold when she's dead
she's a stiff
he was i put my hand on her face
and it was cold you said her face was
cold correct correct if her face was
cold mr durst would you agree
that even though you're not a forensic
pathologist that would indicate she'd
been dead for some period of time
would you agree i don't know whether a
period of time
is five minutes
or an hour or two hours
so it's your position that she might
have been only dead for five minutes her
face is cold and that the killer is
still in the house is that what you're
telling this jury
prosecutors also asked durst about his
missing wife kathy and why he didn't
check with her family before reporting
her as missing
isn't it true that you called the
precinct
to report kathy missing
before you called her family members to
find out if they had heard from her
i called the precinct
to find out
how
to report a missing person but mr durst
wouldn't the first thing you would do
before you call the police when the
first thing you would do is you would
call kathy's family her mom
her sisters her brother
and find out hey listen has anybody seen
kathy isn't that what a normal person
does
well i'm not a normal person
i am told that i am somewhere
on the autistic spectrum
i don't know when a normal person dies
at law and crime has the only cameras in
the durus trial and so we get great
insight like the fact that jurors are
not as attentive as yesterday's cross
could lewin be losing his jurors with
this long cross examination
it's quite possible because this
cross-examination has been going on for
hours actually for days and mr lewin did
say earlier this morning that he'd
probably be cross-examining dirt until
next week at some point you really have
to cut to the chase what are the big
issues you can get him to concede and
keep it moving because this jury is not
going to remember every inconsistency
for the last over 20 hours already of mr
durst yeah he will not
lewin will continue to go i think until
every stone is unturned uh terry what do
you make of durst's belief that the real
killer was still in the house is that a
reasonable doubt
no brian it is not a reasonable doubt i
don't think the jury is falling for that
for a minute it's been decades and this
is the first time we are hearing that
someone else might have been into the
house and so i think lewin was very
smart to
control the situation and say but listen
you you said her body was was cold now
you're saying that someone was in the
house so i definitely think he's caught
in another lie here and i think the jury
is not falling for it yeah the question
is how many lies does lewin want to
catch him in before this cross
examination ends we'll see how this
story plays out thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you